I really think I'm in a good place 20-19
was full of drama for Khloe Kardashian
but she's ready to move on and she has a
message for Jourdan woods I always want
to evolve and grow and mature the
Keeping Up with the Kardashians star
took to Instagram on Thursday to address
backlash from last week's episode of the
reality show and her forgiving attitude
towards the ex Tristan Thompson Tristan
got me a necklace when I was in
Connecticut where he sent it to your
hotel mm-hmm nice
in the episode Chloe's friends Malika
and Khadijah helped her ex Tristan
Thompson gift her jewelry he asked for
help to surprise you with something what
Chloe took to Instagram writing I don't
hold any negative or hateful feelings
towards anyone I mean that she continued
yes I'm allowed to feel hurt and pain it
would be unnatural for me to pretend as
if I don't personally I don't want to be
carrying around a fateful heart fans
were quick to question why Coko doesn't
keep the same acceptance with Jordan
woods following the cheating scandal
earlier this year after Jordan admitted
to kissing the NBA star at a party Chloe
followed up her post saying that message
is for Jordan it's for anyone who has
ever hurt me I'm crazy adding for some
reason people want to assume that I'm
only talking about Tristan this message
applies to all parties involved in
situations that have ever hurt me I have
moved on found forgiveness and wish you
only happiness and joy and despite Chloe
and Tristan split back in February a
source tells et that there are quote no
hard feelings between Chloe and Tristan
if adding their priority is and always
has been their baby true
[Music]